and he is rock-solid there it grows the
work against them though gets by him
produce Wow he can bake there wasn't it
teams battling Andre with a block on
Brogdon Marquis Forrester Bruce brown
ahead to Derrick Rose lays it off inside
and Bruce able to score you know have
something cool
no question Derrick Rose floating gun
Falls Derrick Rose stop and go to the
rim lace it up plays it in count that
baby in a foul zoom some contact and a
much-needed three-point opportunity
against Edmond Sumner Andre screens
Derrick Rose rifles it into the corner
and knocking it down as Tony Snell these
magic players off the dribble David
dumps able to get to the basket and
score his first attempt for the Orlando
Magic tough BA with a a moment from
Dante I really like that one marquel
folks up down a dozen Sexton
he blocks is Brent barn aqui
[Applause]
crowd loves this young bolts again on
the attack beautifully done bunch of
it's the beneficiary of some bolt to
wizardry that can take a game it can
take a half it can take a couple of
hands curving watch the spin ball fake
fake shot is good
[Applause]
56:39 Minnesota
Irving Briggs free its the composure and
it's the strength and he always has his
eye on the RHIB that's a whole lot of
core strength to be able to cook toward
his body the way he doesn't so many of
these finishes over on Alan Stefan find
lavertus Neil Harris right now is the
one on to waiting for his teammates
Kyrie Irving deep three from downtown is
it bad that I started laughing as soon
as he shot the ball but you got the
right mindset right now
Irving a switch he's got Koran
Irving Oh No
[Applause]
I mean watch Irving a3 you knew we
missed it Prince the ball jab jab go
crossover stop
get the body table guys hang in the air
about for bombers this last year for
Washington we will give it up long
rebound field after the mystical Zbyszek
porzingis with his length steals the
outlet pass with fire too long right in
transition yes sir right rebounds valves
up by 16 you can foul you can challenge
if alcohol on your team
it's comes down drills a three stops
porzingis is returned to the game and
here
right down Broadway
down to one minute to play all the love
step back is off target soars over
everyone Blanca block see finney-smith
got the fallback it's picked up by
Prussia
[Applause]
exclamation point Oh
their story with the second effort
Jalen's eventually gonna come up with it
and just like the perfect pass up tumors
Incas of the jam second look same
results
[Applause]
marx continues to hear the boos and kind
of getting less and less Randall gets
inside drives and I'm going to say
before the gather Nero's is six-six
Granville 6-9 and they change the call
Clyde paint one for the steel and the
next come up with a steel next have done
a good job deflecting passage randall
running the floor gets inside layup
flips it up an end that shows you the
agility mobility a Randall so he's a
good Orchestrator rebound the defender
he's on the move now hate gets it inside
likes deep pass inside and Randolph
County and the foul Peyton
thread the needle with the pass Randall
off the San Antonio turnover dribbling
ahead of the pack and finishes strong
Duchamp de Murray slow to get up knock
down the free show pipes in the
preseason and right on cue at the drive
and the Knights finishes he scoops it
off the backboard
looks to the basket best buddy Dennis
Schroder I try to work his way down laws
[Music]
down to the road stuff
[Music]
he's closing out hard they'd only
consume two three all right we don't
we're not sure what he can do once he
can he catches the ball and puts it on
the floor well that's not him doubt
anymore folks ball in his hands yet
again and the drive alone a little
step-back between the legs so smooth
oh just Alexander now with 23 points in
the game the whole just dancing with the
basketball probe in the defense this is
that step back we gotta pick up that
loose change off the field
[Applause]
legitimate history is going right down
the pike straight away Criswell
or tree emotion folks talk about a
couple of big shots Gallo says I can do
it